back to talk conservation rocky spoke
with them about their water smart
landscapes rebate program
here's more so i i know water
conservation is so important here in
southern nevada so what are what's the
update
on our water supply and what can we do
to help well you know the colorado river
which provides 90 percent of the water
for us here in southern nevada
has been experiencing significant
drought conditions over the past
two decades and this year it's no better
in fact we're seeing very low snowpack
in the colorado rockies
and the projections for lake mead are
that lake mead is going to drop another
15 feet this year alone
so it's already dropped 130 feet it's
going to drop another 15 feet but
as long as southern nevada keeps
conserving and keeps saving water
our community will be just fine but
we've got to stay focused on water
conservation
and really rocky the number one way that
we can conserve water here in southern
nevada on a permanent basis
is getting rid of grass and the southern
nevada water authority
has the water smarts landscapes program
it is a program where we will pay three
dollars
for every square foot of grass that that
any property owner removes
and that helps to offset the cost of
making that switch
but more importantly that saves water
and that reduces your water bill
and these kinds of projects upgrading
your grass to water smart landscaping
they pay for themselves over time so
you can make this investment you can
beautify your landscape
and you can get permanent water savings
that will reduce your water bill
great reminder and let's talk more about
the the water smart landscapes what do
they look like what are our options
water smart landscapes are really
intended to be drip
irrigated trees and shrubs that are in a
landscape
it's really anything other than grass
because grass gets irrigated with spray
irrigation
and spray irrigation delivers gallons
per minute
drip irrigation which is very pinpointed
and much more efficient
uses gallons per hour so making the
switch from spray irrigation to drip
irrigation
from grass to plants and shrubs will
save you 55 gallons per square foot
think about this a square foot of grass
requires
10 feet of water every single year just
to survive
that's that's that's the depth of a
swimming pool that has a diving board
10 feet of water for a water smart
landscape
it only uses three feet of water so it's
a significant difference between grass
and drip irrigated trees and shrubs and
your landscape
will still look great it'll still look
green and it'll even bloom with flowers
if you select the red plants
starting in march you can increase your
watering
to three days a week those three days a
week
can be eased into you don't have to go
out and change it all at one time on
march 1st
instead wait until the weather tells you
it's time to change
when it gets hot when we get up into the
70s then you can go out there and slowly
increase your watering from one day to
two days
and then add that third day in the weeks
ahead
to learn more or call the southern
nevada water authority at 702-822-8543
or visit snwa.com
and don't forget the snwa's water smart
landscapes rebate program provides cash
incentives of three dollars per square
foot for residents
residences and businesses to ditch grass
and upgrade to drip
irrigated trees and plants las vegas now
will be